[Music]
sh
all right uh remember and
energetically in your your kihon Wasa he
he do some sort of pushing cuz he's got
to do the spinal displacement and you're
going to have some sort of yield that
then loads the C hand okay so on this
Tachi this hand yielded over there and
this circle went here and that's where
you loaded the C you hand
okay so it goes here
boom there's always that yield uh you're
doing ten net this way not hit here
there's the yield and then the throw
okay
so when you're doing EO there was no
yield on the
elbow you understand there's no yield
that's not what you project
back the yield happened on this
hand remember he's finally displaced him
there that's what you yield and that's
the projection
back you pushed I yield boom is my
projection the hand on the elbow is
there because it will go y it's there
but I'm not pushing it is once he starts
to go back in this projection now I can
enter without clashing on the
[Music]
elbow so you can't bring this out here
and then push his elbow that thing is
y you have a vertical yield
who this is in place waiting for the the
projection to
work boom then I'm
in so identify that as I'm
going
metrics you can use is your
hand then remember this hand is
waiting and the ground hand are in the
same vertical plane they're not in two
different
planes one
one you're going to take the same
plane same
plane then my body does the projection
boom same playing no different
playing same playing
[Music]
no different
planes
no
[Music]
okay mine the chest of
so you're doing an inward
spiral but it's vertical okay it's
vertical this
way so pay attention to my hand I'm not
cutting straight
up like this okay that's never going to
lift his elbow up and that's going to
require me to be in two vertical planes
ever so slightly
here you're going to do your inward
spiral and that's going to make his
elbow up do you see and then that's
where your hand
is you're doing
this so you can't have your
hand without all that
English your hand is flat and your wrist
is
straight okay you'll have to turn it to
get his elbow up so you can get in that
same vertical
plane turn it there's his elbow that's
what I want same vertical
plane you don't want to use your hand to
do the throw because your hand is not
going to be on your Center Line and if
you use your arm give it to me you're
going to use that outer Del
deltoid you bring him
in and your body
projects the opening of the hands that
you're seeing is after he went
in so I'm not going
here that's going to get
you
and and I just stayed with it and that's
when my arms open when he went
y otherwise this is y y clash and you're
just using mechanical engines of the ful
in the lever so you load him Bo and then
you follow it in when it's going that
way that's when your hands
extend Bo body follow it
in if you're
bracing you're going to lose it because
you have to unpin
yourself before you can come
in if you're ground vectoring it's a pul
boom and you're moving
[Music]
in all right let's try those points go